reporter from the United States inside a
holding pen in a Moscow courtroom and a
new low in America's relations with
Russia
the charges against Evan are baseless
and we call on the Russian Federation to
immediately release him he was a
brilliant young man yes Gayle kisselgar
is a Russian journalist
who says he left the country 15 years
ago because he wasn't free to do his job
he told us gerskovic is likely being
used by the Kremlin as a hostage with
orders from the very top I think that
they asked
Vladimir Putin can we do this and he
said okay you can go ahead The Wall
Street Journal published part of a
letter written by gershkovic in Russian
to his parents reassuring them he isn't
losing hope